it's seven hours gmt 10 a.m in the gaza
strip where a new day has come with a
ceasefire and fresh hopes for an
extended break in fighting between
israelis and palestinians
this is the gaza skyline we're going to
show you the most recent pictures
it's a very different scene from the
last 11 days
where the telltale signs of bombardment
were often seen
above the city well that ceasefire
between israel and hamas came into
effect overnight
it's hoped it can end almost two weeks
of a conflict
during which gaza was pounded by israeli
airstrikes
and thousands of rockets were fired
towards israel at least 233 palestinians
died
65 of them were children and 12 people
were killed
in israel
[Applause]
this is how news of the ceasefire was
received celebrations broke out in gaza
bethlehem ramallah and in the occupied
east jerusalem neighborhood which has
been at the center of the most recent
tensions
families in gaza who'd been sheltering
at new enron schools have started
returning to their homes
after the ceasefire announcement many
fled to the schools on the outskirts of
gaza city
the un says nearly 60 000 people have
been
displaced
our correspondent yumna al-sayed joins
us live
from gaza yuma we can see the rubble
there behind you
and once the the happiness that this
news begins to filter through
the rebuilding operation is going to
cost hundreds of millions of dollars
surely
yes peter i mean this is another
neighborhood where i
am now in beit hanon and uh the the
the neighborhood has been massively
destructed so many civilian homes here
have been destructed and not only that
i mean infrastructure also has been
badly destructed here
the water pipes and electricity lines
so basically the people are the
residents of this entire neighborhood
vet hanon most of the neighborhood they
do not have any water or
electricity now which means that uh to
reconstruct
all the infrastructure the roads and
the buildings great amounts of
funding needs to be put in in these in
these uh
areas and neighborhoods so that the
residents can relive in them again
now uh the problem is uh these
these people have moved back to their
homes because of lack of all
humanitarian aid and services
in at unrest schools but are now lacking
the the basic essentials of life in
their homes
okay thanks very much i'll say reporting
live for us there out of gaza harry
fawcett
joins us live as well from west
jerusalem so harry uh the narrative
both sides claiming a victory here is
being built our on our
that's right yes i mean the israelis to
start with the saying that uh the
civilian restrictions that have been in
place especially the ones very close to
gaza are now being lifted apart from
schools uh they're saying the military
emplacements
will stay there for several days
monitoring the ceasefire
and yes as you say both the israelis and
the
leadership of hamas are claiming victory
hamas is saying that it
exacted concessions out of israel both
in terms of
israeli activities in shekshera and
on the al-aqsa mosque compound known as
the temple mount
to jews the israelis are entirely
denying that saying
it is a lie the israeli line is that
hamas has been put back by years that's
what the defense minister benny gantz
says
in terms of these strikes on the tunnels
on missile production
on senior commanders too in turn hamas
is denying that saying that there are
men proudly striding through the tunnels
as we speak so that is the situation
in terms of the victory claims the there
is a political
criticism of the government of benjamin
netanyahu from the right
one right-wing political leader saying
with the advanced
military and intelligence at his
disposal the only thing that netanyahu
has managed to gain
is a ceasefire without conditions so
criticism coming in on that front too
and the core issues were a long way away
from anyone addressing those
indeed i mean we've seen these this kind
of cyclical
nature of these escalations uh the
smaller ones
maybe every few months these very big
conflicts
maybe every few years but but yes i mean
putting aside the uh the claims of
victory on either side
it does look like things have merely
pretty much gone back to
to where they were before all this
things that have changed i suppose
is for hamas it is a way to say
look we have the people on our side
there are these huge celebrations
not just in gaza but also in the
occupied west bank in
occupied east jerusalem and in some
areas
of palestinian-israeli concentration
within israel
as well and so in its political
competition
with fatah which dominates the
palestinian authority
of president mahmoud abbas you can see
after the
cancellation of the elections by abbas
uh just a few weeks ago that this can be
seen as some kind of uh
of victory on sort of bold political
calculations but those calculations
have to be set aside what the cost is
similarly
with israel saying that it has managed
to set hamas back
we're talking about many people dead
many families grieving and a huge
economic civilian
cost to what's taken place harry for the
moment thank you very much harry fawcett
there for us in west jerusalem
well the u.s president joe biden
welcomed the ceasefire saying his
administration worked
tirelessly behind the scenes gabriel
elizondo has more now from washington
president joe biden had come under
increased pressure over the last week
to do more to try to stop the violence
particularly with
progressives within the democratic party
who were calling on biden
to pressure prime minister benjamin
netanyahu to pursue
more aggressively a ceasefire so
ultimately
when biden did announce this ceasefire
he wanted to show that the u.s was very
much involved in it
and wanted to take some credit we've
held intensive high-level discussions
hour by hour literally egypt the
palestinian authority and other middle
eastern countries
with the name of avoiding the sort of
prolonged conflict we've seen in
previous years when the hostilities have
broken out
i believe the palestinians and israelis
equally deserve to live safely and
securely
and to enjoy equal measures of freedom
prosperity and democracy
my administration will continue our
quiet relentless diplomacy toward that
end
i believe we have a genuine opportunity
to make progress
and i'm committed to working for it the
question now becomes is will the biden
administration
use this opportunity to pursue peace
with israel and palestine in the region
we are getting late word now that
secretary of state anthony blinken will
be heading to the region
in the coming days to meet with both the
israelis and palestinians
and regional players to pursue some sort
of peace agreement
where these meetings will take place and
with exactly whom is still
unknown but it does give an indication
that at least
in some degree bain does want to seize
this opportunity
to pursue a more lasting peace in the
region
well omar badar is a political analyst
and member of the national policy
council at the arab american institute
he says washington has been
complicit in prolonging the conflict
washington holds the primary
responsibility here because it is the
only country that holds significant
leverage over israel and is able to
influence its behavior
but also it's not just a matter of
allowing israel to behave however
once or not but the united states is
specifically
funding the israeli military with
billions of dollars every single year no
other country gets more money
in military funding than israel does and
then the united states runs
interference at the united nations by
using its veto more than 40 times
to veto to block resolutions that would
hold israel accountable at the united
nations
so in effect the united states is
complicit it is responsible for the fact
that nobody can hold israel accountable
for its behavior
and that has to change and we are seeing
that it is beginning to change with that
energy in the democratic party now
with the discourse shifting
substantially within the united states
more celebrities speaking out in defense
of palestinian rights
and members of congress now from from
president biden's own party
demanding that he hold israel
accountable and have a different kind of
politics
things are changing people are becoming
much more aware there is much more
energy within congress itself at this
point
where people are not afraid to speak up
in defense of palestinian rights and not
and are not afraid to challenge the
israel lobby's
influence in washington and are
demanding that the biden administration
make good on its claim
that it's putting human rights first if
the biden is going to claim that human
rights come first in american foreign
policy then you cannot continue
supporting israel's oppression and
crimes against palestinians
well the un secretary general has urged
both sides to respect the truce and
renew dialogue to bring about
reconciliation
and an end to division i welcome the
ceasefire between
gaza and israel after 11 days of deadly
hostilities
i extend my deepest condolences to the
victims of the violence and their loved
ones
i commend egypt and qatar for the
efforts carried out
in close coordination with the u.n to
help restore calm to gaza and israel
i stress that israeli and palestinian
leaders
have a responsibility beyond the
restoration of calm
to start a serious dialogue to address
the root causes of the conflict